hola este es el vídeo de química
esencial número 23 y trata sobre los
sólidos iónicos existen cuatro tipos de
sólidos y eso depende de cuáles sean sus
átomos aquí tenemos la tabla periódica
en la que tenemos esta línea del lado
izquierdo tenemos a los metales y del
lado derecho incluyendo al hidrógeno
tenemos a los no metales entonces si
tenemos sólidos compuestos únicamente
por elementos metálicos esos serán los
sólidos metálicos
ahora si solo están compuestos por no
metales que sean relativamente pequeños
entonces serán sólidos moleculares pero
si tienen estructuras grandes en donde
los átomos están unidos covalente mente
esos serán sólidos de red covalente y
particularmente en este vídeo vamos a
hablar de los sólidos iónicos que son
una combinación de metales y no metales
entonces los sólidos iónicos tienen
estructuras hechas de iones que son
átomos que han ganado
los electrones pueden ser cationes o
aniones y se pueden unir por medio de
una especie de cargas estáticas y esas
cargas dependerán de la ley de coulón
por ejemplo si tienen cargas grandes el
sólido tendrá una mejor estructura o
mejor dicho energía reticular y si son
cargas más pequeñas tendrán aún mejores
estructuras y eso es porque las cargas
están más cerca ahora cuáles son algunas
de las propiedades que observamos en los
sólidos iónicos bueno miren los sólidos
iónicos tienen un punto de fusión alto
una presión de vapor baja son muy
frágiles porque se rompen fácilmente y
también son malos conductores de
electricidad cuando están en estado
sólido
sin embargo derretidos pueden conducir
la electricidad y si los disolvemos en
agua para hacer una solución también
podrán conducir la electricidad de hecho
hacer soluciones de sólidos iónicos es
relativamente fácil
algo que sea polar como el agua y como
se ve un sólido iónico bueno se ve así
este es un retículo o red en donde los
iones estan alternados por ejemplo en
este caso tenemos iones cloruro y
cationes de sodio y lo que ocurre es que
transferimos un electrón de unión a otro
así se mantienen unidos por una especie
de carga estática y eso es porque los
iones tienen cargas fuertes pero además
están muy cerca uno del otro entonces
como dice la ley de coulón las cargas
supuestas se atraen y conforme
disminuimos el radio aumentamos la carga
entre ellos ésta es la estructura y
ahora vamos a entender las diferentes
propiedades la primera es que tienen un
punto de fusión alto miren como los
iones se atraen entre sí formando un
enlace iónico muy fuerte tienen un punto
de fusión alto por ejemplo aquí tenemos
sal y su punto de fusión es de 800 son
grados celsius
aquí tenemos azúcar que se ve igual pero
como sus átomos están unidos por enlaces
covalentes su punto de fusión es mucho
menor ok
también tienen una presión de vapor baja
pero que es la presión de vapor bueno si
ponemos un líquido en un contenedor la
cantidad de átomos que salen y forman el
gas es lo que genera la presión de vapor
ejercen una presión y recordemos que
entre mayores sean las fuerzas que hay
en el líquido o en el sólido menor será
la presión de vapor y eso es por las
atracciones que existen en los enlaces
iónicos otra propiedad es que son muy
frágiles si tomáramos un sólido iónico y
lo estiramos se romperá a la mitad pero
si hacemos eso con un metal se estirará
porque es dúctil pero porque los sólidos
iónicos son frágiles bueno porque a
todos estos iones no les gusta estar
cerca de otros iones podemos ver que
todos los iones de cloro están lo más
lejos que pueden de los
iones de cloro y si empezamos a
forzarlos se van a rechazar por eso es
que son muy frágiles y tampoco pueden
conducir electricidad porque no tenemos
electrones libres todo está en su lugar
dentro de esta red sin embargo si los
derretimos como en este ejemplo en el
que tenemos una sal de fluoruro de litio
al derretir la ya puede conducir la
electricidad y si la ponemos en agua
rápidamente se disolverá y así tendremos
un electrolito en el que los electrones
podrán fluir y cómo es que podemos
deshacer los sólidos iónicos usando algo
como el agua
bueno recuerden que el agua es polar es
decir tiene cargas parciales negativas
en el oxígeno y cargas parciales
positivas en los hidrógenos entonces
como vemos aquí la parte parcial
negativa de la molécula de agua es
atraída por el sodio e igualmente las
partes parciales positivas son atraídas
por el ión cloruro y por eso está
rodeado por las partes
en las que tenemos los hidrógenos pero
si quitáramos todas esas moléculas de
agua se volverá a formar el sólido
iónico lo aprendieron aprendieron cómo
se representa un sólido iónico recuerden
son iones que están atrapados en una red
y aprendieron las propiedades las
propiedades simplemente se dan a partir
de la estructura